dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Jonah if I hear this
is a quick report on what is going on
with two minute papers we are living
extremely busy times as i am still
working full-time as a doctoral
researcher and we also have a baby on
the way we are currently a bit over 30
episodes in and i'm having an amazing
time explaining these concepts and
enjoying the right tremendously one of
the most beautiful aspects of two minute
papers is the community forming around
it with extremely high quality comments
and lots of civil respectful discussions
I learned a lot from you fellow scholars
thanks for that really awesome the
growth numbers are looking amazing for a
YouTube channel of this size and of
course any help in publicity is greatly
appreciated if you are a journalist and
you feel that this is a worthy cause
please write about two minute papers if
you are not a journalist please try
showing the series to them or just show
it to your friends I am sure that many
many more people would be interested in
this and sharing is a great way to reach
out to new people the patreon page is
also getting lots of generous support
that I would only expect from much
bigger channels I don't even know if I
deserve it but thanks for hanging in
there I feel really privileged to have
supporters like you fellow scholars
you're the best and we have some amazing
times ahead of us so thanks for watching
and for your generous support and I'll
see you next time